bonjour dans une france qui n'a jamais
été autant boisé la région centre s'en
sort bien avec notamment la forêt
d'orléans et ses 35 mille hectares qui
en font la plus grande forêt domaniale
de france on peut aujourd'hui s'y
promener tranquillement il cueillir des
champignons mais imaginez qu'à une
époque cette forêt était bien plus
habiter 5 heures du matin les premières
lueurs rachat la nuit nos premiers
paysages intimes et éphémère nous avons
des briques la forêt dans les soixante
dix mille hectares dont la moitié en
forêt domaniale
nous assistons dessus de la canne épée à
la naissance d'un jeu
pierre sera notre guide ingénieur des
eaux et forêts la retraite il a passé sa
vie à sillonner nos forêts leur histoire
ici on a la chance d'avoir une la dîme
une dimension de l'espace que l'on
retrouve quand on est en montagne mais
pour la plaine c'est bien ici qu'on peut
retrouver la véritable notion d'espacé
et 1p d'immensité
pour cent arbres en forêt d'orléans lee
a320 sylvestre 50 chaînes et des bois
divers dans notre imaginaire la forêt
d'orléans et le ch ne font qu'un
immuable enracinée comme si le chêne
avait toujours été là pourtant vous
aviez donc au départ une forêt était
constituée essentiellement de bois
blancs et de bouleaux et progressivement
le chêne s'est installé comme dans tous
les autres forêts et à la faveur des
oiseaux qui ont transporté des graines
et où l'amendé d'objets sécurité aux
riverains qui demandent à 100 on a eu
progressivement aussi et à la demande
des éleveurs puisque c'était une forêt
de pâturage
non seulement il y avait du chêne
rougemont avait introduit aussi du chêne
pédonculé qui a un gros fruits qui ce
qui pousse rapidement qui est très
généreux au regard des animaux et
notamment de porc imaginons notre forêt
dans les siècles passés agraire habité
par de petits éleveurs et entretenu par
des centaines de bûcheron qui vivent en
lisière la vie et l'histoire de la forêt
d'orléans sont intimement liée à celle
des hommes de dix grands du ch dron
pouvoir arrêter la forêt baroin jusqu'à
ce que
cour de françois 1er décidé d'émigrer
vers la loire est ici c'était un grand
territoire de chasse qui se trouvait
d'ailleurs en limite à l'époque des
frontières que la france avait avec avec
la bourgogne donc c'était pas uniquement
totalement désintéressé c'était bien de
montrer et d'affirmer que le roi avait
son pouvoir et ses habitudes dans cette
dans cette région avec ses 1500 km2
voire à l'est aujourd'hui un site
investi par les promeneurs maurice
genevoix six réfugiés souvent en quête
de silence et d'inspiration il écrivit
je viens d'ici sans jamais rien cherché
la forêt trouve toujours pour moi et me
donne dans ces zones où le silence est
prioritaire où seuls les chants
d'oiseaux et les couleurs de l'automne
savent vous dire que vous existez mais
que vous n'êtes là que pour un certain
temps je pense que la forêt répond à
l'attenté des gens épargné lors de la
construction de l'autoroute a19 mais
forêt d'orléans reste cependant fragile
sous la pression de l'urbanisation
sa survie dépendra de notre volonté de
perpétuer ce que l'homme a créé de sa
main pendant des siècles